You series today for our
experts in emotion interview.
We'll be speaking with Dr. Daniel Gilbert,
a professor of psychology at Harvard
University on happiness. Dr. Gilbert, um,
is a professor of psychology and has
won numerous awards for his research and
teaching,
including the American Psychological
Association's Distinguished Scientific
Award for an early career contribution
to psychology. And in 2008,
he was elected to the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences.
His 2007 book stumbling on happiness,
spent six months on the New
York Times bestseller list,
has been translated into 30 languages
and was awarded the Royal Society's
General Book Prize for the Best
Science Book of the year. In 2010,
he hosted and cowrote the award
winning Novus television series,
this emotional life, which has been
seen by more than 10 million viewers.
He's also a contributor to time,
the New York Times,
and NPR is all things considered and
has been a guest on numerous television
shows including the today show,
Charlie rose 2020 and the Colbert report.
So finally his first head
talk on happiness is now one
of the 15 most popular of
all time.
So I now turn to our very special experts
in emotion interview together with Dr.
Daniel Gilbert on happiness. Welcome,
Dan. Thanks for speaking with us today.
Thanks for asking me to do this June.
Oh, thank you. Um,
one of the things I thought might be a
nice way to start our conversation today
is to hear a little bit about
where your journey began,
sort of what first got you interested
in the topic of emotion and happiness.
Right.
You know what's funny?
I never thought of myself as an emotion
researcher in most ways. I still don't.
I began my career as a science fiction
writer before I was a psychologist.
I wrote science fiction.
And so my obsession has always been with
how human beings think about the future.
But if you ask why human
beings think about the future,
the main answer is so they can get
to good ones rather than bad ones.
What's a good future?
A good future is one in which we're
experiencing positive emotions.
So very quickly,
if you were interested in why and how
human beings think about the future,
you become a student of emotion.
We're looking into the future so that we
can find more happiness, more pleasure,
and less pain.
So you very quickly get into the
psychology of those particular emotions.
And that's what's happened to me.
So serendipitously you came across
happiness by thinking about the future.
Exactly.
Right.
Awesome. So I want to ask you then a
little bit about your work on this topic.
So I mean you're widely known for
your New York Times bestseller book,
stumbling on happiness.
Um,
that's now been translated into over
20 probably even more at this point,
you know, different languages.
Um, and in your book,
Adn and Australian is two separate ones.
It's been translated into many
Australian has a different dialect.
I mean,
in your local,
it's really interesting and fun here is
that you really challenge this idea that
many of us have,
that happiness seems to depend on getting
what we want or sort of having go as
planned.
And I wondered if you could say a little
bit about how our sort of everyday
beliefs about what makes us happy might
actually be wrong or sort of steering us
in the, you know, perhaps
less correct direction,
right? Will, you know, most people
have a basic theory about happiness.
And this is the theory people have had
about happiness for thousands of years.
As long as they've been writing,
the theory goes like this happening.
This is what happens when I get what I
want. And I usually don't get what I want.
So I'm not always happy. But if I couldn't
get what I want done, I would be happy.
So happiness is just the
product of achieving our goals.
But now for the first
time in human history,
we have large populations of people
living on the face of our planet who
actually have everything they want. And
guess what? They're not always happy.
So you know, there's another beautiful
theory shutdown by an ugly fat.
It can be the case that happiness is
what happens when we get what we want.
So why are we ever unhappy? The answer I
think is we often want the wrong things.
We are, uh, chasing things that
will not actually provide happiness,
avoiding things that will not provide
as much a pain or displeasure as we
anticipate.
So I've been really quite taken with our
inability to look into our own future
and figure out what will make us happy,
how happy it will make us,
and how long that happiness will last.
Um, my colleague and collaborator,
Tim Wilson and I have really spent the
last 15 years trying to understand what
human beings do wrong when they try to
imagine the future and figure out what
will make them happy.
And I think the errors we make
come in two basic kinds. First,
there are errors of imagination.
Imagination is a wonderful capacity.
We're the only animal on the
planet that has anything alike.
The ability to close our eyes and imagine
futures that haven't yet happened.
And yet it's still kind of
in Beta testing. We've only
been able to do this, uh,
for a couple of billion years.
So imagination is flawed.
And when I ask you to imagine what it
would be like to get married or have a
baby or win the lottery,
or get tenure or eat a cupcake,
you do a pretty good job
but not a perfect job.
And the ways in which you do an imperfect
job had been fascinating to me and Tim
Wilson.
So there are areas of imagination.
The other reasons that we chase the wrong
things in our pursuit of happiness is
that we're members of a culture where
members of a society where members of
families in every one of us is
surrounded by a, a, you know,
a big herd of 'em aunts and uncles and
rabbis and priests and philosophers and
grandmothers and bartenders
and taxi drivers.
And they all will tell us what kinds
of things we need to do to have a happy
life. It turns out that some of
that cultural wisdom is right,
but some of that cultural wisdom is wrong.
So we make errors when we think about
what will make us happy because our own
imaginations fail us. And in a
sense, our mothers valence too.
So when you talk about imagination,
I know you've done a lot of work of this
sort of imagining our future emotional
selves or you know,
engaging in what you call of forecasting.
And I wonder if you could say a little
bit about just how our imagination goes
awry and we try to project how
we're going to feel in the future.
Will our bench when the several different,
uh,
independent errors when we
try to imagine the future,
but surely one of the ones that
I've been most intrigued by is our,
our inability to realize
quite how adaptable we are.
Human beings get used to almost anything.
And that's really good when the thing
you're getting used to is the loss of a
loved one,
a or physical handicap.
And it's really bad when the
thing you're getting used to is a,
a new love affair or a promotion at work.
But human beings quickly adapt
to almost any circumstance. Uh,
that's not remarkable to me.
What's remarkable is we don't
seem to know this about ourselves.
And so if you ask people questions like,
how happy would you be if you want
$1 million? I said, oh my gosh,
I jumped for joy.
And they're right.
But if you ask how happy will you be
a year later, they mainly said, well,
I'd probably still be jumping quite as
high, but jumping, and they're wrong.
Within a year, they're going to
adapt to that new level of income.
So one of the mistakes we make,
one of the key mistakes we make is not
realizing the speed with which we will
adapt to virtually any circumstance.
Interesting. And when we
think about, you know,
the sense of which were
sort of more adaptable,
more malleable than we give
ourselves credit for, perhaps
that's absolutely true. Well,
you know, in the negative case,
we are a species that picks itself
up by our, uh, by its bootstraps.
Um,
you know,
we think of ourselves as kind of this
field of fragile flowers that has to go
running to our therapist every
time our shoe laces break.
But the truth is that human beings,
whether virtually every circumstance,
if you look at the literature on
trauma and tragedy, people are indeed,
uh, they, they feel bad when bad
things happen. Don't get me wrong,
it's not good to uh,
lose a loved one.
It's not good to lose
the use of your legs.
But what's remarkable is how quickly
we overcome these circumstance.
Not everybody, but almost everybody. Now,
I'm just fascinated by the fact that
we don't know this about ourselves.
Human beings are famous in
the psychological literature
for overestimating how
good they are at all sorts of things.
This is something we're really
good at and we don't know.
We have this remarkable hidden talent.
And another fact, I mean that you've
talked about when it comes to, you know,
our own knowledge about happiness and
how we're going to feel in the future as
this idea of natural versus
synthetic happiness, right?
And sort of our knowledge about the kinds
of things we think are gonna make us
happy. And I wonder if you could
say just a little bit about that.
Well,
you know what,
these terms are just terms I use to
describe the kind of happiness we get when
we get what we want.
That's natural happiness and the kind of
happiness we manufacturer for ourselves
when we don't get what we want and that
I've referred to as synthetic happiness.
I don't think there's actually a big
qualitative distinction between the two.
And what's remarkable to
me is that people are very,
very good at manufacturing happiness
when they don't get what they want.
Um,
you know,
the moment your fiance throws
that engagement ring back
in your face and starts
walking out the door and she's leaving,
you're looking at her going, you know,
she was never really that cute.
And you know,
we never really had that much in common
and this is actually a pretty good
opportunity for me to start a
whole new life. No, I'm kidding.
Of course you don't do
that the minute it happens,
but it's remarkable how quickly the mind
starts to look for ways to make things
better. No reality is ambiguous. Social
realities, particularly ambiguous.
There are lots of ways to
think of something. Um, yes,
I lost my job and that means I'm
going to have trouble paying my rent.
But the other way to think about this
as a whole new opportunity to become a
poet. There's good and there's
bad ways to frame almost anything.
And the mind is very good
at finding the good way.
Now if you are selling that, you call
it coping. If you're carrying that,
you call it rationalization.
If you're studying it,
you call it cognitive
dissonance reductions, but
it's all basically one thing.
It's the mind finding ways to see the
world that will make the person who owns
the mind feel better about it.
That's what I mean by
manufacturing synthetic happiness.
We're really good at it,
most of us,
and we don't know we're really good at it.
So how do you think then we can
harness these facts about our minds,
things we may be aware of,
and some of the things you point out
that we're less aware of or maybe
appreciate less than we ought to.
How can we use this knowledge to really
find the true secrets of happiness?
Something so many people are,
you know,
so zealous about wanting
to attain and find, you
know, I love the phrase the
secret of happiness. Yeah,
because it's like the phrase to me,
the secret of weight loss,
there's no secret.
Okay.
The second law of thermodynamics tells
you that if you take in fewer calories
than you expend, you lose
weight. It's not a secret.
The same is true for happiness.
We've known for a long time through
folklore what kinds of things bring
happiness and science has by and large
shown that the things we suspected are
right. So there isn't a secret to
happiness. But if you asked me, you know,
what kinds of things, uh,
has science taught us, uh,
even if it's reaffirmed things we
already knew, um, I would say it comes,
there's a few things we
probably know about happens.
First is don't expect to live their
happiness is a place we visit.
It's not a place we move into.
Emotions are meant to be labeled,
are meant to change.
Your emotions are a compass that guide
you through your journey of life.
And a compass that's always stuck
on north is pretty much useless.
So nobody should want to get into a
state of permanent, uh, happiness.
Um, if you accept me happy all the
time, you will be very unhappy.
The second thing I would say is
to watch other people, you know,
imaginations of fickle friend betrays
us in many ways when we look into the
future and try to figure
out what will make us happy.
But we've discovered in
our own research though,
one way to know what will make you happy
is to look and see what makes other
people happy.
You know,
we have this illusion that we're quite
unique in that the things that make
others happy probably won't make us happy.
Hogwash.
We're almost all exactly the
same when it comes to happiness.
If an alien from Mars knew exactly what
made anyone randomly selected human
being on our planet,
happy,
it would know 90% of what there is to
know about everybody else. Um, you know,
would you rather a punch in the
mouth or chocolate ice cream,
gallbladder surgery or a weekend in Paris?
These are, you know, one item Iq tests.
Everybody answers them the same.
So other people's experiences can tell
you a lot about what will make you happy.
Finally, um, you know,
there's a big tradition in psychological
and sociological and economic research
of just looking at the
correlates of happiness. Uh,
what are the things we know about the
people who seen happiest on our planet?
And there's lots of things,
you know. Yup. Money is a,
is useful to have health matters. Um,
you know, freedom and security, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. Is there
one thing that matters most?
Just there is where the social
animal and it's our relationships.
And if you could only tend to one thing
in your life and improve it and expand
it in order to make yourself happier,
I would suggest it be
your social relationships,
your family relationships
in your friendship network.
People who have close family members and
close friendships are rarely seriously
unhappy people.
Hmm.
So it's really all about connecting with
others and making a meaningful social
life in many ways.
Right?
I mean, it sounds trite, it sounds like
something off a hallmark card and we go,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, what's the
secret of happiness is already,
that's like the second law of
thermodynamics. That's the secret.
That's what, that's a wonderful way
to think about it. You know. Um,
I often think of some of my
favorite songs that say, you know,
all you need is love, right? Okay,
you don't even need low.
Um,
looks great but you can get a big boost
just out of conversation. You know,
we know that one of the things that makes
people unhappy is mind wandering when
the mind wanders to often wanders to bad
things and even when it wanders to good
things,
it doesn't usually improve our mood.
But one of the things that holds us in
place keeps us in the here and now is
human interaction.
As I'm sitting here talking to you,
I'm not kind of thinking
about that dentist appointment
next week are wondering
am I really should have said the thing
I said to my wife earlier this morning,
my mind is here.
One of the ways in which
social interaction it keeps
us happy is just by keeping
us in the moment so you
don't even have to have love.
You can actually just have a good chat
with somebody at Starbucks about what
happened in politics the day before and
it's likely to make you happier and keep
you present. Focus to
present focus. Right.
So of the other things that
I really love in the work you do
among so many things is that, um,
some recent work,
um,
where you found that people systematically
underestimate how much they're going
to change in the future when it comes
to personality traits, personal values,
and even, you know, preferences.
And it sounds like from
your work at people come to
believe that they've changed
more, you know, in the past 10 years
and they will in the upcoming decade.
And I just wonder,
you know,
what do you think this suggests about
our understanding of ourselves and who
we're going to be in the future
and what we're going to want? Will,
the phenomenon you're talking about
is something we've called the history
illusion,
this kneeling,
but people have in every age from 18
to 68 that they've changed a lot in the
past, but they're pretty much done
changing. They finally become the person,
they will pretty much always be,
yes, I'll have less hair. Well,
for me that's not possible.
Uh, and more pounds as I age,
but I'll still be fundamentally the same.
Dan Gilbert,
I do feel that now at the age of 55,
but I also felt that at the age of 25.
So what we've established is that this
is actually a widespread illusion among
people of all ages.
But I think it's part and parcel of
a bigger piece of our psychology. Um,
we're very much prisoners of the moment,
uh, as, as you've said in your own work.
Uh, we're stuck in time.
We're here now and our,
our perceptual reality,
the here and now is quite palpable and
quite powerful and it's very difficult
for the mind to escape the moment and
travel to the future or travel to the
past.
So I've referred to this phenomenon is
presentism the 10 our tendency to be kind
of stuck in now, when you try
to imagine yourself in 10 years,
it's really hard to do.
That's a very difficult cognitive process.
Who will I be in 10 years? What will
I be? What will I be doing? Well,
I want how might my values change?
And I think what happens is when we
have trouble imagining ourselves being
different, we mistakenly conclude
that that means we won't be. Actually,
what it means is that imagining yourself
in the future is a hard thing to do.
We should scratch their heads and go,
I just can't imagine myself 10 years
from now. And so I'm uncertain.
But instead we say,
I can't imagine myself 10 years from now.
I guess that means I'm going to
be the same guy. I'll always be.
The problem with this of course is that
by overestimating the stability of our
current selves, of our personalities,
values and preferences,
we can make bad decision making errors.
So for example, we asked them one study,
we asked people to uh,
how much they would pay to see their
current favorite band play a concert in 10
years. And I average, they
told us about 130 bucks.
But when we asked them how much they would
pay to see a concert right now by the
band, that was their favorite 10 years
ago. They said only about 80 bucks.
So people recognize that they still don't
now love the band they use to loan 10
years ago quite so much, and yet
they're very confident that in 10 years,
Radiohead is still going to be the
band that they really want to see.
So you can see that this end of
history, illusion, but can the devil,
our decision making,
well, when it comes to radio
head, perhaps that's timeless.
10 years from now, let's get back
together and see how you [inaudible].
Yeah, I feel, I mean
in some ways, you know,
what it suggests is that we're more
comfortable sticking in this sort of more
pleasant,
comfortable present as opposed to a more
uncertain and perhaps anxiety ridden
future where we don't know what's going
to happen. Things are out of our control.
Unpredictable.
I do think it's comforting to
believe that you finally arrived.
The development is a process.
It's tumultuous, it's hard,
it's revolutionary and evolutionary.
Finally,
I'm done on finally fully formed.
It's delivered me to this moment and I
can be this Dan Gilbert for the rest of
my life. I do think most people
take some comfort in that.
So I think that's probably one of the
things that causes the end of history.
Illusion.
Personally.
I'm rather glad to know that I'm
going to completely transform.
I plan to be a six foot tall, blonde
Swedish man, right, about 10 years.
He, you know, you never
know. Right? Odds are small.
I mean, I'm just wondering what kind
of implications do you think this has?
You've talked a little
bit about, um, you know,
the kinds of things we think we're
going to invest money and in the future,
but the sense of,
you know,
our future selves being relatively
stable versions of our current selves.
How do you think this will affect the
kind of choices we make? You know, um,
in terms of saving money for a trip or
putting, you know, time and money into,
you know, investing for College, um,
how does this change the kinds of choices
you make in terms of what we think is
going to make us happy?
Because much of our time is spent building
towards this future self is going to
be happy.
Well,
I think it suggests that we're going to
make mistakes in an even suggest what
kind of mistakes we're going to make.
We're going to tend to build futures that
are current cells like that our future
selves don't. But it's the
classic example is the Tattoo.
A tattoo was a commitment to a piece of
art on your body for the rest of your
life. Now, you know, they
can mostly be removed,
but it's long and arduous. By and large,
when you get a tattoo, you're saying,
not only do I like this now,
but I will always like this.
And I see young people walking around
all the time with these very cool tattoos
and they locked extraordinarily up and
they're not going to look extraordinarily
up when their grandparents or were,
they're the CEOs of large multinational
corporations or when they're soccer moms.
But they believe that a young age that
if I get a tattoo now all always like it.
No, we make fun of young people because
we think they don't have much foresight.
They don't realize that
they're going to change.
And what I love about our researches,
it turns out their grandparents make the
same mistakes, just not with tattoos,
but 50 year old people
vastly underestimate how
much they're going to change
between 50 and 60. So this isn't
just an error for young people.
It's an error we fall.
Make. How can it change?
How can knowing about this change our
decision making? I think probably the, um,
uh,
the watchword is options.
That is to the extent that you realize
you are likely to change much more than
you would intuitively think.
But change in ways you can't predict.
You leave your options open.
You don't make serious commitments
to things in the long term. You know,
most choices are not just for the moment.
I decide what to have for lunch right
now and I'm deciding what will make me
happy now.
But when I go grocery shopping,
I'm deciding what will make
me happy for the entire week.
Most decisions are decisions about
what our future cells will want.
If we recognize that our future selves
are likely to be different than our
current selves in ways we can't predict,
we leave our options open.
So we shot for three
days instead of 30 days.
We signed up for a six month
gym membership instead of
a 10 year gym membership.
We get the a Henna Tattoo
rather than decline.
But it has to be removed with a laser.
I mean, it makes you think too, um, and
some of the professional goals that,
you know, uh, academic
scholars like yourself pursue,
we're constantly pursuing these
long longterm goals, right?
And we're sort of set up in a profession
that's having us work towards goals
that in many ways perhaps we don't know
if there is there going to be the same
goals that we're going to want
in two years or five years.
That's right.
And you know what I'm saying?
I don't need to be suggesting we
should all live for the moment.
Forget about the future far from it.
I'm a big believer in
longterm future planning,
but I think what we have to do is make
a plan for the future knowing that our
future selves might not
be very happy with it.
And so there are exit
strategies all along the way.
We allow ourselves room to grow
and as we sort of think about
growing and into the future,
it makes me think of a question I'd
love to hear your thoughts on which are,
you know, you've done such wide reaching
work on happiness, mind wandering,
this idea of our future selves,
how we're going to feel,
how we're going to imagine
our future selves to be.
And when we then think about the
future of the field of emotion.
It feels funny to ask you this
question now, sort of, well,
where do you think it's headed?
Well, I mean, first of all, um,
I hope it's headed for oblivion,
which is to say almost any interesting
field should transform so that 30 years
later it's not recognizable.
Emotion is an artificial category.
Emotion is a English word in English.
Words don't carve nature
at its joints. Um, know,
think of words like, um, time and
space. They're very different words.
And so we thought they
were very different things.
And Einstein came along and said,
you know,
these two categories you have of time and
space, it's an artificial distinction.
Time and space are
actually the same thing.
Four dimensions of the same thing.
I think that's instructive right now.
We think there's a study
of a thing called emotion,
but emotion is just some dimension
of our subjective experience.
Subjective experiences have this quality
of being good or bad of feeling a
positive or negative.
They have other valence and we should
be very interested in that fat.
But it's not a fact that somehow separate
from all the other facts about us as
human beings. I mean, when are we, when
are we not experiencing an emotion?
When are we not having an emotional
experience? I think we always are.
So I think as we come to
understand more about the body,
about the brain and about the mind,
this distinction between emotion and say
cognition is really going to disappear.
Um,
with that said,
you've asked me to make a prediction about
the future of my field. And you know,
if you go back and look at scientists
making predictions about the futures in
their field, they're almost
always wrong. If that's,
because if I actually knew what
the future of my field would be,
I'd be doing that. I'd be there. So
for somebody who studies
how bad predictors are, I'm
going to sit back and say,
the only thing I predict about the study
of emotion is that it's going to be
really, really exciting. That's
a pretty good prediction.
Stiff can't go wrong there.
So, I mean, related to this then,
when you have students coming to you,
undergraduates or graduate students or
just general interested people wanting to
pursue topics like emotion or happiness,
what kind of advice do you give them?
Well, I think for somebody who is
starting out in the study of emotion,
um, first of all, it's a bravo.
You are studying the single most
important thing about human beings. No,
he sounds self serving,
but it really isn't.
Think about what Plato said this.
He said,
when we say something is good or bad,
what are we really saying about it?
Except that it brings pleasure or pain to
human beings by studying hid Dominic's,
by studying what makes
us feel good or bad.
You're studying the essence of what
we're doing here on earth. I mean,
to me emotion defines value,
which is to say nothing is good or
bad in the world except because of the
emotions or feelings that
it brings to human beings.
And so I think you're studying the
single most central aspect of the human
condition. So congratulations.
Um, practical advice.
Certainly.
Uh,
you need to understand physiology and
you need to understand neuroscience.
This is where lots of exciting things
are happening in the study of emotion.
Connecting our deep understanding of
it as a subjective experience to our
understanding of how the body and
the brain producing modulator.
So I think anybody only understands
the physiology or only understands the
psychology is going to be
left out of the future.
I think the future belongs to those who
really are going to understand how to
put these two things together. But I
suppose my, my watch word would be,
don't forget that what matters about
emotion is subjective experience.
What matters is that we
feel that and if we didn't,
we wouldn't care very much about them.
I think it's going to be very
easy in the future as we,
particularly as we gain expertise,
more expertise in the neurosciences to
lose sight of the experiencer of the
person who's having the emotion.
And I think if we do that,
we've lost sight of why we're
studying emotion in the first place.
Well thank you so much for speaking today.
It was a pleasure.
Mine too.
So this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Dr. Daniel Gilbert from
Harvard University.